hi herzlich willkommen zum heutigen
video ich bin hier zusammen mit macht
sang mit luca und ihr seht schon zwei
schilder auf denen die namen des jeweils
anderen stehen wir spielen heute wer
würde er ja wir kriegen fragen gestellt
von der betreiber neben der kamera sowie
venedig leute denken ob die rechnung mit
der ersten frage werden kennt die fragen
und wir sagen während er machen wäre er
bei shopping queens für männer nichts
machen da gibt's umklammert naja ich
finde den anspruch mit dem budget es ist
eigentlich positive wendung ist ein
bisschen in wien versteht nicht als cool
ab heute geld umsteigen auf achten
spieltag bekannt
[Musik]
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch an die
nation
da ist mir mit dieser werte her nicht
die hauptverfahren untergewand die wir
heute hier herrscht die kämpfe noch mehr
verstehen aber wir weiterkommen luca
verkackt da für mich andere wasser
fischer essen geholt dann wahnsinnig
macht überhaupt keinen sinn weil du
springst runter und da eine sekunde
seines sohnes und ende hatte der krieg
aber bei mir etwas auch durch verstehe
auch nicht nur diesen in adrenalin ich
glaube also mache ich wirklich
ausprobieren würde
kann ich zwar auch belasten die platte
springt bei dax-gewinner mut in der luft
gibt so alle sobald er in der stettener
abwischen und drei spiele mit tanzen
viel aufregender ist alles zu house
running und bewaffnet eine ganz andere
hat okay nächste frage wer würde er eine
schöne macht mir den film schönheit und
gefragt ob platz sie kennen sich ja ab
und zu trainieren ja keine arbeit
gemacht stimmen ja könnt ihr ja ich also
ich glaube wenn ich also von von uns
beiden zumindest würde ihnen sagen dass
ich eher mit dem aufhören würde um
irgendwie nächsten produzieren was aber
dem hinterteil gewundert dass nicht er
sondern ein bisschen dafür interessiert
aber dann hat jeder alles überhaupt
etwas mit also ich hätte mir nur gedacht
weil ich mein verhalten für youtube ist
die alle paar tage mit luca haftet also
jeden tag an dich gedacht dass du da für
beide staaten mit musik vom 5
aber du vielleicht weniger bereit
aufzugeben hierauf der festivals ganze
kraft für egal
nicht die frage oder wartet mir dürfen
verfestigen werden würde er ein jahr
lang komplett
[Musik]
ich habe immer so fahren nicht sagen
am wochenende dann alle wieder
viele hätten ist irgendwas hochgeladen
eigentlich mit feingefühl eigentum ich
bin drauf und dran das durchziehen
gerade als ich lebe ich schon gesund
bisschen wie geritzt täter beobachten
und brot tomaten brot käse auch gern
viel gemüse ja auch gewitter mit tomaten
gemüse reis nach europa retten
ungesundes dem einer dieser tatsache
dass du frühstück irgendwie hab ich bei
dir war ich könnte doch ein kleiner
brötchen wird salat und irgendwas drauf
und du kennst die zwei türme größeren
kaffeeküche in die arme aber jemand muss
man muss also zumindest frühstück immer
sie es erwähnt wird ja auch gesagt dass
theoretisch volker gut sein sollen
morgen theoretisch hätte apple server
fed sehr gut zu drücken wir es einfach
ich guck doch nach draußen
kampf nicht drehen scheint gucken und
dann gucke auf die pflanze jedoch daher
genau das richtig gut
weiter mit der nächsten frage und hat
nun fünf mal mit drei leicht wie beim
auch gut sie mal drauf
es gibt für die wii
[Musik]
pnp de wit gefällt immer mehr
marktanteile gewonnen 3 1
also kam auf 83 mal bekomme ich vom kopf
her glücklich und ich habe mit meinen
wirtschaft werden auf welche natürlichen
macken
im shop machen bei 100 leicht macht
erhält mit während bullock an eine
banane stange hängt ja ich bin vergabe
ersten die taktung aber ich weiß erfolg
geschäften so landschaft betrachten
ich kann mir das gerne geben wie werde
ich reich bebilderter halt nicht weit
und breit wird es einfach wie in dem
maul und hat einen schönen auftritt
ruhiger wird es gibt für eine woche oder
monat aber so ich schätze das einfach
mittlerweile werde alles vor der tür
beläuft supermärkten eine minute
firmencup jede minute und weiter jett
ist nie wieder auf jeden menschen in den
von der stadt
das geht doch tafel ist aber komplett
lahm
3 mit beidem
also ich finde die idee eigentlich immer
wenn ich kein modell mehr über die
technik helfen
also ich meine im prinzip wie locker
schmeckt nicht wirklich an nicht meinen
fangruppen hat ja einfach irgendwie
abspecken und meine pfannkuchenteig und
nur den teig mit ich gleich findet ihr
meine grünstadt in die comments abwegig
also mit kate middleton will kommt es
zum kampf findet der ausfahrt ketchup
mit nun interessiert man sich auch weil
viele herunter und auch aus
ich hätte mit so lecker wer im
schlusssprint aber die augen offen
halten und dafür auch noch vage hoffen
dass für die welt über machen habe ich
macht mir auch wenn es beim sanieren
oder ja der vergeben oder auch gemacht
new york muss ich das noch machen und zu
beginnen und bis heute nicht bei myvideo
mit dem anderen
du bist bist du bist dabei die gebrüder
ein wenig milch mit ja dank mehr
videomaterial videomaterial den leichter
uns vielleicht gehört für mich mit mit
einer gehörte video einige bei
youtube.com erfolg war ein pferd kaufen
23 und warum solchen twitter bekannt
ihre ich werde ich mag denn mal fertig
machen und meine laterne
nein also ich wollte als kleines kind
tatsächlich 5 bar oder sowas
er hat mit meiner bohlen und seine
mutter hätten
ich war dass polen holen das ist mein
revier hat apple geschrieben bevor ihre
jacke und ab mir hat aufgetreten und mir
gegen den kopf gekriegt arbeitet mit
fahrrad und der vaart dem ist dritten
lagers begrabt mein putter fallen ja ich
bin geschichte also wirklich ein
schicksalsschlag warm aber von marken
wie stimmte durch wird seine göttliche
dafür die erfassten geschichte beenden
wir das heutige video sein
hier geht's zum video da gibt's zum
knopf zum abonnieren klick auf beides
aber erst abonnieren das video haben wir